good I feel like I'm at the weirdest bar
ever
yeah so do you just gosh I was like one
of the seconds to start I feel like
that's something we should hash out
right mullet vs. mullet feel well
there's you know I'll be honest with
there's no hash out to be happen you
know it's like you know a friend of mine
who's right showing it in it oh yeah
that native is more native yeah my
support is mine is definitely a little
bit more British one guy with a drum in
front of me you know
yeah me do somebody throws something
somebody throws a frickin pineapple over
your shoulder something somebody yeah
somebody throws a spear yeah somebody
carves you up and makes a [ __ ] chubby
soup you know that's your stuff anyway
dude I got this because I was so
inspired by your live bro oh thanks man
your sexuality didn't even ask me about
it you just got it
no because I don't think I need to ask
it's like you know but what about in the
80s dude when like people got parachute
pants mmm-hmm right my body Ramone hmm
got parachute pants oh yeah yeah baby
what is he and he was like and he was
like pop lock-in and [ __ ] right
hmm I didn't call him a go hey can I buy
those two and do the same moves no I
just I've made my mom go to Nordstrom's
yeah I got the ones with the most
pockets that's one way to do it man
you know I think though if I would have
said like hey I want to you know put on
a little put on a couple pounds you know
and maybe chop chop a couple inches out
of each one of my legs you know what if
I want to do that you know what if I
want to you know what if I want to kind
of make myself look like I had just at
the very end of a sneeze you know
and but I didn't call you first
yeah that sound like I just that's the
only thing I thought oh let me think
about that you know well you know Touche
Touche to you well right right harden
Touche okay and good day sir okay
alright but what I want to reiterate
back to you dude
is is I could have I could have done
this
hmm then bleached my skin mm-hmm right
and then taking some brain cells out of
my brain right philosophical ideas about
life
yeah right and then I could have added a
couple of inches to my legs mm-hmm right
got a truck mm-hmm right and then peed
on your lawn like you just peed on mine
earlier yeah I had to pee that's why
what happened did you pee on a plan a
little got on the concrete but not that
much I mostly plan so as long as it was
you know absorbent it's fine yeah yeah
that's how that concrete looks pretty
absorbent yeah yeah I think yeah so what
you're saying to me is I should have
called you
yeah said hey buddy the next time I see
you yeah I we look alike then right but
yours is different than mine yours is
much more like of the it's more Mowgli I
feel like you know I'm saying his is
just more you know more like oh like
missing-person style ah like an 80s kind
of synth band
yeah some like that or this guy's Oh
have you seen this guy and like now I
haven't seen him in never seen him you
know and they just keep showing the
picture around town you know disappear
educate me yeah I thought he was the
lead singer of missing persons for a
second you're talking about right I
think you're talking about Mowgli
missing / I thought missing persons was
the 80s band you were talking about
Mowgli was the lead singer of missing
person sorry man
yeah
that was my bad though it's both of our
bad dude I can't believe we get into
conversations because that's what our
conversations are like on the phone oh
it's only yeah we talk about we're
talking about I'm like here the phone
come on Olympics did the phone cut out
you're like nah conversations well we
have a media we talked at the comic
store we don't really know what we're
talking about yeah yeah it's limited
it's very limited well Bobby's a hit
and-run conversational and stuff on a
lot of times he'll get in the show up
say a couple things couple dis that
right and then he's gone he's off to the
next I think just about including me